Stay still get out of here
Fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
it's not just a call
it's a warning
I've been trying to reach you oh my god
this is about a king and riddler's
the match i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be
long before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
go take it easy sweetheart hear
everything they say thank you
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
I'm vengeance
What's black
and blue and dead all over
I got you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
batman trailer video matt reeves and robert
pattinson dropped a brand new trailer with
a whole bunch of new footage and easter eggs
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a bunch of other trailers that they also
release too that i'll be doing videos for like
the flash movie with the other versions of batman
ben affleck's batman as well as michael keaton's
batman but we'll just go through the trailer
shot by shot starting at the beginning here so
we start on a shot of the riddler with gordon and
the gotham city pd coming to arrest him so it's
probably a little bit later in the film after they
discover his crime scene and start to pick up on
his clues that edward nigma is the person leaving
all these clues and i do love the question mark
easter egg in his coffee cup and i think i figured
out what's going on with the riddler's clues here
that he's leaving in this giant crime scene
that's featured very prominently in the trailer
when it says the sins of my father i think that's
a reference to bruce wayne's father like the sins
of the old money of gotham not doing anything to
help gotham the way they should mitchell is the
name of don mitchell the former mayor of gotham
city that is killed by the riddler in the trailer
it's implied that he was corrupt like he says no
more lies then under no more lies there's the name
coulson and that's a reference to gil coulson
who's one of the gotham city prosecutors the way
that peter sarsgaard explained his character is
that he said he's not a very nice person so when
he says no more lies it's implied that maybe gil
coulson is putting people behind bars that don't
belong behind parts like he's prosecuting the
wrong criminals whereas the riddler is trying
to get batman to serve true justice and get rid
of all the corruption inside gotham renewal is a
lie might be part of some bill that they're trying
to pass in gotham city like you would revitalize
a downtown area do some project to try and fix
things up but because of what the riddler is
doing it sounds like this is all being controlled
by the mob element like carmine falcone in the mob
as well as corrupt people inside the government
of gotham city then the reference to savage is
probably just the riddler calling batman out for
how nuts he's going on criminals all over the
city the past year the way they said when the
movie picks up the people of gotham city don't
really know whether batman is a friend or foe just
because they hear about this guy that's dressing
up like a bat going around beating the crap out of
criminals everywhere so there's this real cloud of
suspicion and he's incredibly violent so people
think of batman as being just like the other
criminals as well kind of and even though it's not
a direct batman origin story it's batman year two
there is a lot of origin stories going on
for some of the other classic batman villains
like something of a riddler origin story in a
catwoman origin story you also probably noticed
the soundtrack that's playing on this trailer
too so it's a slightly different version of that
nirvana cover something in the way they played it
on the last big trailer too and also some of the
new batman theme music at the end of the trailer
then we get the narration from robert pattinson's
batman talking about the bat signal itself about
how the bat signal isn't just something to alert
him to communicate with him it's also used to
inspire fear in the criminals like the way he uses
fear as a tool we get a much longer version of
this scene of him beating up this gang all dressed
with the skull makeup the funny thing too is that
you may have noticed is that one of the actors
here in the background actually plays tim drake
robin on the titans tv series also on hbo max
then we get our first scene with batman going to
confront the riddler in prison about everything
that he's been doing the clues that he's been
leaving to him the same way that alfred's dialogue
in the last trailer made it sound like the riddler
had been sending messages to batman for a long
time in these different crime scenes around
gotham and obviously you watched the scene of
them confronting each other and it feels very much
like the dark knight where batman was confronting
the joker trying to get information out of him
i made the david fincher zodiac comparison when
talking about this version of the riddler in
my last big batman video just the way that he's
using ciphers and clues just seems very similar
to the way that the zodiac killer left messages
also the zodiac killer in real life were a mask
that looks kind of like the mask that the riddler
is wearing during this as well so even visually
it seems like he's inspired by the actual zodiac
killer this scene outside on the steps with all
the different characters all the major characters
seems like it's part of the mayor's funeral
like you have bruce wayne along with selena
kyle carmine falcone you also have the penguin
everyone from the government the police department
as well as the criminal underworld of gotham the
mobsters all meeting there we get way more footage
of batman and catwoman together i love the way
that they're lighting this too they actually said
that they used some of the same stagecraft as the
mandalorian with those giant led walls to do some
of these big city shots but the footage gives you
a much better sense for the vibe of her character
during this film it seems like they have great
chemistry but just like many versions of catwoman
that you've seen in the past even though it's
clear she's very intrigued by him she still kind
of wants to be her own person do her own thing
pretty much what you'd expect from catwoman she's
not really meant to be a good character or a bad
character she'll often team up with batman just as
often as she'll team up with the villains we get
way more footage of colin farrell's penguin now
even though it seems like he's a big part of this
movie colin farrell said that he wasn't in a ton
of the movie but there are some really cool fight
scenes with him i'm assuming he'll be much bigger
in the sequel we finally get some scenes with
andy circus's version of alfred we heard him in
the last trailer but we didn't actually see him
on screen in the conversation he's having with
batman feels very familiar almost every version
of alfred has had this conversation with batman
at some point early in his career the way that
robert pattinson explained batman right now during
the events of this movie is that he's still
so fresh as batman during year two he doesn't
completely delineate between where bruce wayne
ends and batman begins like there are no limits
like he doesn't really think of himself as having
two different personas so he's kind of always in
batman mode but he hasn't developed the playboy
bruce wayne persona that you see from other
versions of batman like when christian bale's
batman came back to gotham to put on the cape
and cal he'd already fully developed that playboy
persona we had a couple more big fight scenes i
love the fight choreography here and obviously
they're trying to make this feel very different
from the fight choreography in the dark knight
trilogy or even during the zack snyder dc films
the other really cool thing you probably
noticed in this trailer is the way they
color code different scenes there's the orange
colors as you see the sun going down there's the
blue of night then there's all the red colors
in other scenes particularly the fight scenes
catwoman asks him who he is under that cowl
obviously she probably does not find out in this
movie be a little bit early for that to happen the
clever way they play that and a lot of versions
of the character particularly in the comics is
that she just winds up figuring it out on her
own because she is a really smart person and they
spend enough time together that she does figure
it out before he decides to reveal it himself i
also love the sound design the way they play some
of these scenes later in the trailer especially
the way they light up the scene here with the
gunfire tell me this does not feel like the darth
vader hallway scene from rogue one like give me
darth vader wrecking all the rebels but make it
batman and they're really awesome chasing with the
penguin and the new version of the batmobile where
he totally thinks he's got him then he just comes
barreling through that fire you have to imagine
that he probably destroys the batmobile every
single night that he goes out in it and he just
doesn't care because he has so much money that it
doesn't matter like he could destroy a car every
single night and replace it and it would only take
a fraction of his money to fix that couple great
scenes of him gliding through the city and then
when the riddler says what's black and blue and
dead all over matt reeves actually tweeted this
out what i think the riddler is taunting batman
with what's black and blue and dead all over
is that he's talking about batman himself or he
could also be talking about justice but the reason
why i think he's talking about batman himself or
bruce wayne is because he's black and blue like
he has bruises all over himself his costume is
black so he's physically black and blue but inside
batman bruce wayne is kind of dead like he died
the night that his parents died and he's kind of
been this ghost of a person just existing until
he decides to become batman and then develops
that new persona as the batman and bruce wayne
but like i said per robert pattinson's comments
he hasn't completely figured that out in this
movie he doesn't know where bruce wayne begins
and batman ends that's why you haven't talking
to characters like alfred saying i don't care
what happens to me and characters like selena
kyle trying to counsel him if you keep this up
you're going to die and he just doesn't care
what happens to him because as the riddler
taunts him he's dead inside but if you guys have
a different take on that riddle let me know in the
comments if you think it means something different
what's black and blue in dead all over i also love
the small detail you notice here too on the news
broadcast that the riddler live streamed one of
his killings may have been him killing the mayor
which seems like a very modern thing to do if it
wasn't clear this is taking place in present
day on earth too that's why they're putting it
in a different universe so they can explain why
it takes place in present day when you have ben
affleck's batman who's in his 40s in present
day on the main justice league earth you also
see batman putting on the cape and cow and matt
reeves had this really cool easter egg he said
during robert pattinson's first costume test they
used the val kilmer costume for him to audition in
robert pattinson was putting on the eye shadow
camouflage makeup that batman wears under his cow
and matt reeves thought the scene of him
putting on the eye shadow was so cool that he
just incorporated something like that scene into
the movie so during the movie when he's putting
on the cape and cow we'll see a much more extended
version of that like him putting the eye makeup on
usually in a lot of batman movies you get a
suit-up montage where it happens really quickly
then the way they in the trailer here with this
upside down shot of the penguin looking upside
down and you're taking his perspective watching
batman walk away from the fire this just looks
so badass but what i'll do tomorrow is i'll do
a longer batman trailer video with that other
featurette footage there's a whole bunch of
other behind-the-scenes footage and a bunch
of clues about what's going on with a bunch more
easter eggs so look out for that tomorrow also my
flash trailer video as well there were a couple
other big trailers i'll try to do videos for
everything in the next couple of days so make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss anything everyone click here
for my black adam trailer video and click here
for that other new batman footage i'll update
the link as soon as i post that video tomorrow
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!